d-backs have won five of six they've
already clinched a second consecutive
series win today
they look for a three-game sweep of the
phillies with mad bomb on the bound he's
your diamondback starter today madison
bumgarner his 19th start and has pitched
very well
big cut at a curveball and mad bum gets
his first strikeout i guess that answers
our question when he will incorporate
his off speed stuff big loopy curve ball
here
he gets bryce harper way out in front
really good location that time too swept
across the strike zone and ends up down
low and away
2.56 era he leads the league in
strikeouts and innings pitched
in fact if he holds that lead
for the rest of the year
he'll be the first phillies pitcher
to lead in innings pitched in strikeouts
since lefty did it
in 1982
swinging a miss at a high fastball
one out here in the first one for two in
game one of the series with a run scored
in a walk
skies that one down the left field line
toward foul territory thereas makes a
basket catch going away what a play
by ronald torrez
i think the only one that was able to
get there
that took so much concentration and
athleticism
this is not an easy play
at all
looks like it's the lightest crowd of
the the week
they've had about 7 700 the first couple
games
i don't think they're going to reach
that mark today no
swing of the miss at a fastball at 98
miles an hour
and one out here in the third
here's the 2-2 pitch swinging the miss
he struck him out
that's pretty nasty right there
yeah
no chance
you know chase is all about it looks
like
almost i i could be wrong it almost
looked like brian holliday walked away
and said wow
no fooling around here
a strike three call there's the call
from tom haley and he just struck out
the side
that's four strikeouts for zach wheeler
can't have an all-star at every position
why not well
you can
the bat is shattered into several pieces
walker collects that they get harper
who is oh for two and there's splinters
all over the field
thank goodness for the netting yeah
that was headed for the stands and that
is uh
that's a spear right there
[Music]
he's left holding that tent peg in his
hand the barrel and the splinters went
flying all over the field the barrel
ends up back against the screen would
have gone up into the stands
christian there to collect that 11
straight set down by mad bun
this is shaping up to be one of those
games that usually is swung because of a
mistake or an error either a physical
error on the field a mistake by a
pitcher leaving a pitch in the middle of
the plate
fair ball down the line there's the
diamondbacks first hit
no freight train heads for second he's
got a two out double and a nice job down
there by
scoop chuck oliver to get himself out of
the way that one that was coming right
at him
our golden glover in left field
david shoots it right down that third
base stripe a 97 mile an hour fastball
just off the outside corner stayed right
on it
drawn is at second
now with two outs in the fourth inning
of the batter is walker
that's trying to get down here comes
harper it gets in there
peralta will score diamondbacks grab the
lead back to back two out hits against
wheelers
a broken batch single to shallow right
field between the sega basement segura
and harper and the diamondbacks take a
one-nothing lead
boyd tied him up big time in there again
broke his back
and luckily there's two outs for the
time of acts as peralta would not have
been able to score if there was less
than two outs as this ball drops in and
nothing harmful
he wanted to get up there and make
something happen
alec balm leads off the phillies fifth
ellis at third spins and throws a nice
scoop by christian walker at first base
ellis really made christian work for
that one a terrific pick many times
you'll see two good plays ellis goes to
his left does the reverse spin and then
throws a short hopper over there the
first base christian walker really had
to go get that one
they're leading today one nothing
the o2 is a swing of the missed by
turrets he strikes out that's number
three for bob garner and two outs down
the fifth inning
d.d gregorius the runner at second base
luke williams at first
two and two on the pitcher zach wheeler
got him looking at a cutter
four strikeouts for mad bummy strands
two and leads it one nothing
stranded two of the fifth and now segura
starts us off in the sixth ellis in
front of aubameyang spins and throws
drew ellis nicely done
well that was not an easy hop for drew
ellis i thought he might let it go to
nick ahmed right there
drew gets over there plays that last hop
has to come up on it the reverse spin
and this time he gets it over there in
the air to christian walker
walker sends it to left center that's
going to get to the wall christian's on
the move
and he'll pull up at second it's a lead
off double he's two for three
boy a lot more patient lately and a lot
better results for christian walker is
he going to see a curve ball
on the ground thereas and walker was off
the bag and somehow
got back safely says corey blazer
christian walker was a dead duck down
there joe girardi wants to have a look
somehow he avoided the glove of tires
it was kind of a perfect storm for
christian the ball hit right to the bag
thereas was
there oh get skinny
nick has driven in
27 on the air this would be a huge one
right here if he can get the
runner home from third base with less
than two men out and withers pitch to
him is a line drive that's fair down the
line and left extra bases one is in here
comes the other runner around third come
to the plate ellis and he will score
it's a two-run double ahmed and a
three-nothing diamondback lead
wheeler tried to come back inside with
the fastball and this time he didn't get
it down and in he got it up a little bit
and ahmed drilled it right inside the
bag cleared the bases
bumgarner shatters the bat mccutcheon in
pursuit it drops in for a hit and a run
on that is home it's four nothing mad
bum the rbi single
[Applause]
have a day madison bumgarner man
dealing on the mound hits that one right
off the end of the bat looks a little
like bryce harper earlier in the ball
game as that pat splits in half
that drops out there andrew mccutchen
cannot make a play diamondbacks tack on
another run
got three runs in two on and two out and
van meter come to the player on the
seventh any chance to have more
the pitch with the runners going and a
shot down the right field line and that
is a hit into the corner it's going to
score a couple
bumgarner right on his heels rojas two
run double by van meter and diebacks
have broken this one out it's a five-run
seventh inning and a six-nothing
diamondbacks
that was so impressive
and then he wins the at-bat by hitting
that line drive right inside the foul
line down the right field line clears
the bases again
six runs on eight hits for the
diamondbacks
ground ball out towards shortstop it'll
get a run home
they get the middle runner at second
roll to second van meter goes the short
way mad bum escapes only one run aloud
it's a six to one diamondbacks lead
not over yet
as the phillies
got a one-hour rally going with a double
in a single first and third
a live drive out to left field that's it
for a hit an rbi single for the reyes he
has two hits this afternoon it's now a
6-2 ball game
chase is loaded for the phillies in two
outs
off the middle for ahmed
ball game and sweep diamondbacks take
all three they win the finale six to two
you